Living with monks? Yes. What is
it called? Living with the monks.
Living with the monks. Um,
does your new book? Yes.
Why did you start to do that
and how long did you do it for?
I did it for 15 days. I was enough.
That's more than enough, man.
Yeah. We're going to go like this for
an hour. Your finger all fall off.
What are you doing with your finger?
Up and down? Just a repetition.
What did you have to do? I uh, well I live
with, they were, they were eight months,
four, which had been there for
50 years. 50 50 on a monastery,
800, 800, 500 acres, kind
of in the middle of nowhere.
And um, I went for 15 days.
So I figured, you know, I,
I'd invested so much of my life on the
physical side and ran a hundred miles and
just always active and this and that and
have really invested very little on my
own inner work. And I just felt like, man,
I just felt overwhelmed a little
bit. And I said to my wife, you know,
who are the masters? And everything
pointed to monks. And I said,
I want to go live on a monastery. There's
something romantic about that, right?
It's almost like the guy who goes
off into the woods to write a book,
like being with a,
with a monk like,
and just being in a monastery with monks.
There's something very
romantic about that, right.
Does that you've shed all your worldly
belongings and you no longer care about
the day to day nonsense that everybody's
fixated on. Just decide to just, Oh,
[inaudible]
yes. Oh, all day. You could do it.
I don't want to do it, man.
You should want to do it.
I've lived the opposite of amongst life.
My life is filled with bullshit.
I get it. Yeah. Where'd you go? So I went,
I went to a monastery just south
of Canada in the states. Ah, yeah.
But no, what state is it? It was in
upstate New York. Oh, okay. Yeah,
like on the Vermont border.
And it was, um, you know,
no phone total kind of separation
from my family. I have four kids,
my wife and just got to, uh, get
to know myself a little bit. Wow.
Now, when you were up there, was
there any time where you're like,
what the fuck am I doing?
Like one minute into it,
I got, when I first got up there, the
main monk, like my goto monk, brother,
brother Christopher took me to my room.
They call the rooms that a cell,
which is about the size of this
table. And I had a bed. I walked in,
there was a bed,
there was a little desk with a night
lamp on it and nothing on the walls.
And he said,
tomorrow we're going to start prayer,
reflection and meditation at 7:15 AM.
And I looked at my watch and it
was 6:00 PM and I asked him, well,
what do we do between now and 7:15 AM?
And he looked at me dead in
the eye and he said, you think?
And I said to myself, I'm fucked. Ah,
because I'm like,
I don't really like spend a lot of time
in thought. So I went and I said, okay,
I'm going to, I'm going to
meditate. You know, like I'm here,
let me start this journey with meditation.
I'd taken the little a course
in transcendental meditation.
I'm not a big meditation
guy other than running.
And so I set my timer for 20 minutes
and I sat down in my chair and I started
like focusing on my mantra. Like
immediately I'm bombarded with how it was.
My wife had the kids, the hawks,
it's like all this, you know,
bumping against the Atlanta
Hawks. I live in Atlanta, like,
you know about your kind of
hawk. Everything's coming
at me. And um, you know,
time is going by and I'm just getting
bombarded with thought and I'm like,
why isn't my timer buzz like it's been,
I've been here forever.
So I was going to look and reset my
thing. I'm like, that would be cheating.
Let me keep going and going.
And all the time's going by and,
and finally I'm like, fuck is
going on with my time or, you know,
so I opened my eyes and I
looked to reset my timer.
It's three minutes and 27 seconds.
No, and I said to my, I like studying,
really thought it was 20 minutes.
I thought it was like hours, man.
I mean like I'd never really sat in a
room like with nothing going on and just
closed my eyes alone and
thought and time to stop.
And I calculated how much time I have
left, like 15 days times, 24 hours,
a 60 minutes. And I said to myself like,
man, I'm in trouble. This isn't like,
like this isn't what I'm
on Gilligan's island.
This is a real like I can't
get out of here. And I,
I had a really hard time with it.
What was the commitment?
The commitment was 15 days. So the only
you, it was a personal thing. Yeah,
he did it up to you. Like there
was no, nothing in writing.
And did you have a way to escape?
I mean I was thinking of escape plans,
but I'm on the monastery and this is a
little crazy that the way the monks keep
the lights on is they breed German
shepherds. That's how they make money.
They breed. German shepherds
are the largest I've seen
is they wrote a book. Yeah,
they wrote a book. I have the book. It's
a book about raising puppies. Correct.
The same guys. Same guys.
Oh, so they weren't Buddhist.
They were Russian Orthodox and
they raise German shepherds.
So they live on this property and there
are these 11 German shepherds and at the
end of the property,
the only way off the property where
two mobile homes unconnected to the
monastery at the end of this road
that leads up to the monastery.
And both of those homes had German
shepherds as well that were a little
territorial. So there really was no
way for me to escape. Like I couldn't.
I ran 120 miles up and down the driveway
while I was there because I couldn't
leave the property.
So you just timed herself or paced
yourself using an APP or something?
I said like 2000 steps equals a
mile. You counted your steps. Oh,
Jesus Christ, dude. Yeah.
I counted and I marked it.
What did they think about you
running back and forth like that?
Thought it was a fucking psychopath.
I'm like,
you guys have been here for 50 years
then I'm just trying to get some extra
sales. What are the, the guys like
that had been there for 50 years?
Uh, quiet. No they were,
they were extremely listened to date.
They were doing what they wanted to do
with their life. So they were super happy.
Really? Yeah, super present.
I mean very present and I mean I live
in a world that to do list man and like,
you know, they were very
present, very happy and really,
really nice to me. And
everybody. Did you talk to them?
They speak English. What was the
conversation like? Like what, what,
what do you say to a guy who's
been in a monastery for 50 years?
Just staring at the walls while I wanted,
if I could have talked
to him about the pageant,
that would have been just a conversation
he brought. I know, super confusing. Uh,
when I first got up there and they would
ask me a little bit about my background.
I told them, you know, I was
in the private jet business.
They didn't understand private
jets really. And then I said,
I had a coconut water company.
They never heard of coconut water.
I told them I was involved
with the Atlanta Hawks and
one of the monk said, Oh,
I've been to a an expos game.
And I'm like,
that's a different sport and they
don't play, they don't exist anymore.
And this is very like time warped
at first. It was really interesting,
really interesting. Jesus. Now what led
these, these guys that are 50 years,
50 years on the Montessori, how old
were they? Uh, so some of the, the,
the age range from,
I think the youngest monk was
probably 35 up until late seventies.
So late seventies with the guys
that had been there for 50 years.
They checked in when they were 20. Yeah.
And the young twenties in the same spot,
they actually built
this monastery by hand.
They bought 500 acres for very,
you know,
I think it was like $50,000 or
something. I mean, something crazy.
And then they built the monastery by hand.
And so it's been a passion of love and
labor and they've been there since.
And so the vow of celibacy, the
whole deal and celibacy, poverty,
poverty and sober 20.
Yeah.
They take a vow for things of um,
celibacy.
Poverty's, they pledge all their
personal belongings to the monastery.
So really the only possession is a
driver's license, obedience and stability.
Meaning we're not leaving. This is
what we're going to do. So I mean,
talking about discipline, just off
the charts do forever. Forever.
And where do they get funding?
They're self sufficient. So they,
they breed German shepherds, they sell
them. That's kind of one income stream.
And then their master's world,
masters of dog training training.
So every two weeks they have 10 dogs
that come in and they, and I've,
I watched this,
I mean they literally,
dogs come in like spuds
Mackenzie and leave.
Like they just left etiquette
school. Like it's, it's, it's,
it was like anytime you're in the presence
of the people that are the best in
the world and what they do,
it's fucking fascinating.
And these guys were masters.
They are the masters of imagery that
there's a lot of people that are great but
in their space of dog
training and breeding.
What was so special about the way they
train dogs? Just the command like,
like they had an energy
that the dogs responded to.
I mean like I would walk in and the dogs
would go crazy. They'd sniff my nuts.
They just, they go nuts. Right.
These guys would walk in and like they
could just sense that they were in
control, they were in control and like
the eye contact that they, everything,
the way that they talk, their
tone, their hand mannerisms.
They just have mastered this and they
have a deep connection with dogs.
Dogs are weird in that way.
Like I have a one year old golden
retriever and he has different rules for
different people and he knows who he can
get away with what with like my wife's
mom has zero shot at controlling this
dog. Like it's like, he's like, ah,
no, no, no. I'm the boss. I
think I'm going to jump up on
you and kiss. Yeah, yeah, no,
no.
I'm going to just run around and put a
pause on you and you sit in a chair and
you know, we're like, Marshall, come
on man. What the fuck? What is this?
You don't do this?
And it doesn't matter when she's here,
he just decides Mac new set
of rules with this lady.
She doesn't seem to know what the
fuck to do with me. But when, uh,
I had a trainer that I worked with him
for in the beginning when I first got him
and when Ryan, the trainer comes
over, he just like sits down,
he's super chill, he listens. He's like,
Oh, this guy knows what the fuck to do.
Yeah. He knows how to control me.
Right. So it's, it's very interesting.
He's even different with me
than he is with my friends.
Like my friends would come over, it's
like, let me try you out, motherfucker,
pause on you and see what's up.
And I wish you would be like across the
board with everybody. But he's just,
it's all love. So it's not bad. You
know, he's just a lovely dog. Yeah.
But just like pause on you and shit. You
know, and I'm not really a dog person.
I liked dogs, but we have one. No,
no, but we don't really connect.
You don't connect with the dog.
I mean not like instant love when they
see me the way that they are with other
people,
I don't know.
But the monks were using that
were teaching me various lessons,
almost like karate kid
style through the dogs.
So like the first day I got there, every
day I was signed to different role with,
I would shadow one of the monks and
there were eight and they had different
responsibilities around the monastery.
The first day I was in the training
center with one of the monks,
there was training the dog and
my job was to be the distractor.
So rainbow,
this dog would walk around and I would
fucking go Adam and jump and run and like
try to, you know, whatever, get
them to break his goal of going.
They would kind of simulating a park
scene or a city scene and making this dog
not get distracted. So I would go nuts
with the pork chop and this and throw it,
whatever. The dog would just go
unwavering from point a to point B.
And the monk said to me at the end, he's
like, it's just like life man. He's like,
if you have
goal,
just like rainbows goal
is to get from a to B,
you can't be distracted and your goal.
And I was like, that makes sense.
Some karate kid stuff. I
was like, Mike Song. Yeah,
like wax on and but all these
different lessons started to emerge.
It was pretty interesting. Wow.
So that, that isn't just, it's,
it's interesting too that they're doing
it with German shepherds are really,
really smart dogs. I want
like, what's a dumb dog?
Uh, what's like a generally
thought of downward dog?
Let's think.
Trying to think like what would
generally be thought of as a dumb dog.
There's no like prejudices for dogs,
right?
Is there, this is like, like one breed
or you're like this dumb fucking breed.
I don't think of like when you say like
a dumb dog, this dumb individual dogs,
but I don't ever think of like, oh, that
there's some dogs that are like spastic,
right? Like Jack Russell
terriers are kind of spastic,
but that's because they were raised
to kill rats and they just like,
they have a high kill drive and
they're super hyper. But like,
I can't think of a dog
that's supposed to be stupid,
but German shepherds are generally
supposed to be smart English bulldogs,
but I don't know if that's really true.
I think they're just lazy. Man. My dog,
Brutus is half English
bulldog and half Sheebu.
He know he just has bad joints
and he's just lazy. He's
just, I don't, he's stupid.
He's kind of a Dick.
He's a dick to other dogs.
But I just think that's because he's in
pain a lot. These dogs were super smart.
They're so smart, man. Those dogs look at
you and they love, they're sizing you up,
checking you out, see what the fuck
you're up to, make sure you're cool.
But there's really this feeling
like they know they can kill you,
like they're looking at you like I could
kill you but I'm just checking you out.
I had that feeling that they could kill
me too. Yeah. It's a real feeling. Yeah.
Yeah, they can. And they
be like, I was scared.
They were sensing that he's trying
to like down downplay my fear. Yeah.
My friend who trains them
has a dog that's like,
he does police work and
it's like a serious fucking
dog and he'll attack like a
thing.
If you're holding like a stick,
like on command and he jumps
and one of the things he does,
he bites the stick and then to pause,
go right into your nuts.
And I don't think it's on purpose,
but damn, it's an effective strategy.
Like it's like bite and then nuts
stomp all in one maneuver. Right?
Yeah. But those dogs
are, you know, they're a,
they're a dog that's sort of bread and
designed for protection work and police
work and stuff. Yeah, they are. And
they train their dogs for as pets.
So they didn't do any kind of, you
know, police work or anything like that.
So that the 11 German shepherds that
were the property was super well behaved.
I mean,
like ridiculously well behaved.
So when they train them or they just
training them to make sure that they're
obedient, you know, they just listen,
wash the house, bark at strangers,
that kind of shit. Yeah. Hand signals,
obedient, you know, not jumping,
but really that, you know,
they know who's in control.
So did these guys do that before they
started running the monastery or was it
something that they decided to do while
they had the monastery? No. So they, uh,
they fell into it.
They didn't go up there that none of them
had any experience in dog training. Uh,
they, that wasn't the intent. They just
said, we got to keep the lights on here.
And they had a dog,
they had a dog as a pet and
fell in love with a dog.
And ultimately they, when the dog
passed away, they all got killed. Uh,
they wanted another dog and they went
to a breeder and they got two dogs.
And they actually just, they
realize that they, you know,
once they bred an amazing puppy,
I live their first litter,
that and train these dogs that there was
demand and they just scaled it like any
other business, you know, and they
learned along the way. Trial and error,
just like any entrepreneur. I mean
these guys were like, first of all,
they were monks and there they're
super spiritual. They're religious,
they were Russian Orthodox, they
weren't, they're not Buddhist. And, um,
but they're amazing entrepreneurs.
I mean like they ran this thing
super efficiently, but the,
but the point would only be to make enough
money to keep the lights on. Correct.
So as an entrepreneur,
it's almost like they're,
they're limited in their ambition.
I think excess,
you know, it's not like they're, if
they have excess money and revenue,
it's not going to material things,
but it's for the life and
the extension of them,
of the monitors monastery and put it
away for taxes or what have you. Yeah.
Or they have, you know, they're
in the hands of God. They have,
they don't have a lot of litters or
they don't have a lot of puppies or they
have no income. Right, right.
That's fascinating. Now these guys,
what do they do for recreation?
Uh, they pray, Jesus,
they think they read,
what do they read and they have
like an amazing collection of books,
fiction,
everything really super well red.
So they do have some entertainment in
terms of like fiction. Yeah. And you know,
periods of it. And that went up
there with no expectation. The only,
like I'd heard of monks,
I watched,
I've seen monks in movies and read
articles and blogs, but I never,
I didn't know much about it,
about the culture,
certainly about Russian Orthodox and the
different factions and this and that.
Um, so I went up there, eyes
wide open and um, but I,
I went up there really just to detach
and get away from feeling overloaded and
feeling distracted.
And Man,
I'm a father of four and I have a
business and my wife has an entrepreneur,
et cetera. And I just wanted
to see like, you know,
it's kind of been my journey.
I learned best by diving into the unknown
just like I did with Dave and it just
says I have done in
businesses and other things.
It's just like I learn best
by going into the unknown.
So I didn't do a lot of research around
them or how they made money or this or
that. I just kind of
showed up. Wow. That's a,
it's a crazy undertaking. But I guess
if you knew you only had 15 days,
at least you have like some
light at the end of the rain.
But when that 15th Day came and what
did you get in a car and drive away from
that place? Yeah. How fucking good
did it feel? Did you check your phone?
It felt really good on day.
What's going on on Twitter?
Like Day four and five I was
already kind of making excuses.
I was rationalizing in my head
that's seven days would be enough.
So like in my head I was going home
day seven. Oh, well, I mean I was like,
no one's going to know the difference
or care if I went 15 days or seven days.
Or is that like if you're at mile 50
and you're like that's enough. It is.
Same kind of thing.
Same kind of thing until you wake up the
next day and you're like, I dropped out.
Right. And you feel like,
you know, so, um, anyway,
I decided like, you know,
I'm going to stick this out.
And then when I left it was a, it was a
good feeling and the feeling was proud.
I felt proud of myself for sticking
through it. You know? Isn't that funny?
These guys had been there for 50
years. 50 years, man. And you're like,
I did two weeks, man. Yeah, it felt good.
I bet it's it. It also felt
good to go through a bed. Well,
it's the 50 years when
you're describing that,
that seems so insane to me
that I can't even relate.
But when you're talking about your 15
days, I'm like, man, you poor bastard.
Like I feel bad for you.
The guy that 50 50 years,
he might as well be living in another
dimension. Yeah. As far as I'm concerned.
Yeah.
I mean when in there in his
twenties that is just so nothing,
no sex, no family, no, no neighborhood.
Nope. No fucking hobbies.
No drive to work. Nope.
Fuck. And you know their,
their impression of it is like,
we made this decision so it's not,
we didn't sacrifice it like we decided
this is the life we want to live,
but when he made this decision, it
was 19 what? 1960 [inaudible] shit.
Black and white TVS. Oh my
God. That's a crazy decision.
That's crazy to, to
decide back then like, I,
I see what's coming and I've had enough,
I've had enough these daily newspapers.
It's just too much
information. Right, exactly.
That's a crazy time to check out.
So they don't know what the
fuck's going on in the world.
Did you quiz them on shit, I didn't
really quiz them. I mean they,
every Sunday night they have one,
there's one TV and one back
room and they watch the news.
So they get a sense of just like,
you know, it's kind of where we are.
State of the war. Yeah. If
there's a nuclear meltdown. Yeah.
One hour. Uh, yeah. They watch
about an hour on Sunday night,
one night a week. And that's how
the tuner, who do they, who did,
he was going crazy. I was immediately
like, my head went to like,
I'm sure we're being attacked right now
and I'm stuck at the monastery. Right.
Yeah. I'm sure the airlines are flying
and I'm stuck here for another 30 days.
Right.
No,
my mind went to a place where I was
thinking just the worst of everything.
You know, what news do they trust? Uh,
I think they trust it all, but like
which channel do they go to? Oh,
they would just watch like,
you know, uh, the local ABC,
see the local whatever is local
in the upstate New York. Okay.
They weren't Netflix options.
Do they have internet?
Uh,
I had no access to the Internet and I
think they have access probably for their
job, but I didn't know access. So the
dog training Jesus Christ, it was,
it was wild. But why is that so
romantic to people? Because it is,
it's very romantic, right? There's
something about this idea of checking out.
Just, I had a buddy who did it mean
for all I know. He still does it.
I lost touch with them 25 plus years ago,
but he was a a taekwondo guy and he
started to meditate because he was always
very nervous about sparring and
very nervous about competition.
So excuse me, he was trying to figure
out what was going on. So he said,
let me just take some meditation classes.
It took some meditation classes and
really enjoyed it and got really,
really into it.
And then one day decided to give up all
the worldly possessions and all of the
trappings of civilization
and move into the monastery.
And I remember we went up and
met him for lunch one day.
He'd also become a vegetarian.
So w you only ate vegetables and we
were all just hanging around and he,
he seemed oddly a piece and it was so
confusing to me because at the time I was
like probably 20 and I was just didn't
know what the fuck is going on in the
world. He was maybe 10 years
older than me and this guy,
he just decided I've had enough. It was
weird to me though. He made me nervous.
Like, you know, like he made me nervous
that like, he was on to something.
It may be nervous that
he was wiser than me,
that it highlighted how fucked up I am.
And you know,
especially at 20 years, it's
so life is so chaotic, right?
No idea what the future holds for you.
If it's going to be success or failure,
if you're going to slip it every
fucking banana peel you run across.
But he seemed to have it figured out,
sitting there and eating vegetables,
all common shit. Where's he now?
I've no idea. I lost touch with them.
I lost touch with them, you know,
probably like 30 years ago. But, uh,
when I was 20,
those guys freaked me out too.
They must have freaked you out just
when you did this book. I mean,
I freak them out. Really. I was an alien
and I came in there high energy, you know,
rod rod, like he's the only
guys ever done that. Uh,
probably probably at this particular
place I think for an extended period of
time like that. Yeah. Wow.
What w w why they let you do it?
Well, I had written a book, Pryor,
uh,
living with a seal and they knew I was
coming up there to write a book and uh,
I guess they liked the first book.
Well,
I'm sure it'll be good for the dog
business too. Yeah, yeah. Yeah.
So they read your book,
they read my book.
Were you allowed to read books while you
were there? I was allowed to. I brought,
I brought, uh, I'm not like a big reader,
so I figured two books would carry me for,
for 15 days.
But I read them know I read
both in like the first day,
like the first two days because so then
I was like a check whatever they have.
Oh look, Mary Poppins. Yeah, I read
the stupid shit. Yeah, I said I'm good.
Just thinking.
Wow.
So was there any point at
like day 13 when you're like,
I actually kind liked this?
Yes.
I think around day seven
once I realize like you know,
I got the excuses out of my head that
I'm staying, I'm not, I'm not leaving.
I mean this, this is what I'm
doing and I settled into it.
I got tremendously energized because
like at the monastery you don't make any
decisions. You eat when they tell you to
eat, you eat what they tell you to eat,
you go to service when the
church bell rings you go, you,
you w w one outfit. I showered
once. So all of these,
all the decisions were
taken away from you.
But when all the decisions are taken away
from you, it frees up so much energy.
So as we're getting like super
clear, and I was like, I liked this.
This is like no one could get to me.
I'm not getting bombarded.
No one can schedule appointments with me.
This isn't so bad.
Have you ever done the sensory
deprivation tank? [inaudible]
there's the thing about the sensory
deprivation. You know what it is, right?
The thing that's most interesting about
it is that in the absence of input,
your brain is freer and you can make
decisions better and think about things
better because there's no input coming in.
You don't think about it.
But as we're sitting here just touching
this table is input you and not looking
at each other across the lights.
All this is input.
And in that tank there's no input.
And in the absence of input,
if frees up more resources for your brain.
So in a sense,
what these monks you're saying or doing,
by having everything on a schedule,
you don't have to think about anything.
And there's nothing coming in.
There's no Twitter, Facebook,
all that jazz. You're,
you have more resources. Correct. And
you feel better. That's exactly right.
That's exactly right.